you know what if there was a shift
it's all about like will's like what i'm
leaving my
i'm leaving taking my talents with me to
atlanta to the south like lebron what
he's doing and he just slapped chris to
be banned from the oscars because he you
know he already had another team
ready to scoop them up
yeah
atlanta team
now what if atlanta hosted like
something like the oscars not like
source awards you know like something
like
bt
do they even have bt movie awards
yeah it's uh whoever gets i called
police in a movie theater
that's the tyler perry movie 101 right
there you ever get beat up by a girl
watching the toilet paper
no you know like it was like authority
specific to you yeah oh yeah i'm just
asking because a lot of guys to be like
cheating on the girls in the movie
oh so they come in there like what do
all guys think like
she got mad at you because she's like
this is like i think yeah
you don't want girls knowing how guys
think i'm talking about like if a guy
cheats on his wife or something
and there's some like mannerisms
that women see and that kind of compared
to your relationship and the next thing
you know you're getting punched in the
arm
after a certain scene
and you're like why you punch me in the
arm and then she's like do all guys do
that i was like you should have asked
before you punched me you know
i got hit a couple times watching tyler
perry movies jesus with different girls
just one crazy latina woman yeah i think
that's the problem that one lady i don't
think it's the movie yeah it's just yeah
oh yeah are you talking about your baby
mama yeah the ex
what happened with the crystal
the crystal
no
on my birthday she gave me uh like i
gave him a question he gave me a crystal
dude because i what what like what is
that called you're into what
astrology i'm metaphysical so that's
cool yeah i think it's called [ __ ]
that's what all men think so she gave me
this big ass crystal wrapped up in like
serene wrap
and uh she said it's supposed to take
away all the negativity in your life and
you know did not well i got divorced
right after yeah like still was beating
a lot of shady people like right away
immediately just [ __ ] accident do you
think it was a
positive thinking or like you a placebo
effect or you're like it's supposed to
be like this so then it started
happening and you're like oh look it's
magical crystals yeah
i told her i told her about the whole
situation after i got the crystal
i don't know he started banging crystal
i'm actually on crystal meth now it's
been working a lot for me so i i do like
crystal
you like crystal yeah yeah you look more
like heroin i was i actually was
yeah no i don't think chris enough yeah
i was a was a junkie
that sounds awesome oh yeah it was until
it wasn't right yeah
yeah
i love so what's
so what's happening with you man like
what's what's what's been going on how's
austin treating you
so this guy on kill tony
watches me on kilten was like if you
ever need car
help you can contact me
and so i told my girl about him because
she needed car help and now she went to
him and then he [ __ ] up her car
nice and now she doesn't have a car
i bet she wasn't even a mechanic at all
like it's like i'll just help he's like
a hobbyist yeah so is she mad at him or
mad at the recommendation the reference
like
she's like hey i don't have a car now
thanks a lot hans yeah i'm gonna show
her now it's just yeah it's like she's
trying not to be mad at me but how did
she mess up her car what what yeah
i don't know he was messing around in
the engine
she was like i need my something fixed
and i was like oh you need your spark
plug fixed and all you try to give it a
tune-up she's like a higher fix and he's
like getting that engine real quick
yeah he was open miking
the car engine nice so you guys start
somewhere it's the same thing with
mechanics
but you know i have a platform so i can
dox him i know his address and his phone
number and his instagram oh nice so are
you holding that little drum follow up
on that too
i mean you could box them right now to
be honest oh yeah yeah i could get the
balls rolling
did you guys have to pay him at all or
not yeah
she would let people know who not to
trust with their cars
if we could start a list he's not
mentioning it was he mexican no he was
white boom there you go
he's cool guys
yeah
[Music]
so the car won't start at all you should
close the door i'm sure eddie could fix
it
you can eddie can you take it
and do the lawn too
the lawn i would love to do your lawn
bro it's pissing me off how long it is
you don't even feel comfortable walking
on your lawn barefoot well you know you
might you're from the jungle right
yeah i'm from the
jungle me
i'm moving amazing
koreans were in vietnam we were fought
alongside the americans
and you guys apparently because you're
in america
yeah
south vietnamese i'm guessing yeah or
something my god
yeah my grandpa fought alongside america
is that the jungle south vietnamese
yeah out of this jungle
yeah it's like chilly it's so long
so do you have like a trade a trade
village where they trade like
monkey skin
vietnamese women yes that's nice
talking about a wet marker they call
circumcision
monkey skin
do vietnamese people get circumcised
no
i hope not
maybe south vietnamese
african circumcision
a different area
but that's how you tell the gallon is
good if you can walk barefoot in it
yeah
it's safe it's safe
you don't know bro you probably got some
[ __ ] in there
just don't hurt your feet man you can't
even tell this request is too long
yeah actually if you invited like a
mexican parent out here they'll be like
[ __ ] out here
isn't this natural
you can smoke some of this
i'm sure some of that's here
just deep in one of the
am i too loud
was i loud on the headquarters i mean
you're loud in general i just wouldn't
say
no just like
i think the levels are good
um i'm just saying like on the car right
here you're loud
oh how is the car right over here it was
interesting but we got we were out right
away
it was a moment where there was a cop or
you know a state patrol highway patrol
was like next to us
[ __ ] we were like we just smoked it was
driving super chill i was driving the
hallway [ __ ] that's the worst person i'm
driving i mean
i crashed my car i crashed my car
weeks ago
and i was going to say ava
anyway why
she that rhymes
but uh yeah i mean she's a woman i mean
you guys are great to drive asian women
like really shiva at least looks like a
tech kind of guy yeah i don't know nerdy
but you you're like you're two in the
cool world yeah he was wearing the
sunglasses the whole ride down
that's how vitamin d gets in bro
yeah you're probably not but these these
glasses weren't that expensive to block
the vitamin d i'm pretty sure i'm still
good actually i don't think you can
absorb vitamin d through the car window
yeah it's like
right next to it going like this yeah
there you go you will probably have to
do that
i got natural filters
it was uh it was interesting we did stop
at bucky's you know shout out to booker
oh god that's a bunch of overrated like
you guys all over it hating on bucky
yeah she wasn't overrated
it is a nice restroom
it was clean you're right you
know what you need
you need a bathroom it's got everything
that a car traveler could want
exactly yeah
yeah a lot of trucker stops that are
good to do yeah he's gonna take a dump
you got privacy yeah they had hand
sanitizer inside the stall
oh wow inside this yeah
it's like they're gas stations they got
like 700 stalls yeah
they got [ __ ]
3 000 pumps i mean it was crowded please
charge
we're not even using this anymore
we'll get copyright
yeah but there's like three thousand
whatever it was crowded so it's been a
year so far huh oh yeah in austin yeah
atx
you know what man we got to talk about
it bro cause i was so happy when i saw
you on that jet dog
eating steak did you already talk about
this did y'all bring it up a little bit
oh man
what was it dog like how was it wait
wait wait wait
what happened i don't even know what
happened uh he posted on his instagram
that you know he was going to was it
jacksonville yeah and he wrote on the
jet with uh tony was it rogan's jet yeah
and he was eating a little nice steak
that's they look nice bro yeah nice
we ate steak every day three times a day
just stick stick steak
out
i need any help on the plane
like you wouldn't be like on screen at
the ufc yeah i had to take two shots for
that who's your pet with my girlfriend
amanda okay
it's pong dang right yeah
that's what he says when he sees me on a
private jet punk dang
god damn it didn't you yeah yo i saw you
at the ufc fight yeah but that arena
dude that really looked [ __ ] dope
[ __ ]
yeah your first arena like bigfoot my
first arena i like how everyone is like
is that your first arena yes
believe it or not i was hosting for
ludicrous but it was a whole different
kind of vibe i was hosting so it wasn't
like they weren't ready for stand up i
was just like you were doing something
i
yeah that's different but yeah
i was sort of sort of like that you know
did 15 minutes
went through my jokes you know it's
weird it's like comedy but not like
comedy
it's like it's like comedy because you
got to pay attention but it's not like
comedy and that
it's like hard to get a connection or
you're positive because you're talking
airborne yeah
it's like 700 comedy clubs
there's one section that gets it the
other section is like
black
[Laughter]
so it was you uh tony and uh joking yeah
yeah actually
he's dude
you hung out with somebody afterwards
because they took a picture i tricked
that david yes yeah this was
that's pretty dope man he's like a
very uh charismatic man
just love that dog
yeah i was looking i was like man hell
yeah you deserve this [ __ ] bro you've
been doing it for years you're like what
i consider a true comic because this is
your life yeah you know that's how i
feel too you know yeah comedy is a like
thing life to see yeah i mean there's
not a lot of us yeah we're doing it you
can actually kind of tell who's actually
living that real comedy [ __ ] yeah
because they're kind of detached and
uh stoic and you know
over it all and gay
ready to get canceled yes
what are you gonna do kid it's a comedy
business gabby no i i love it it's not
like i'm jaded at all it's like still
like the first day i don't feel like
i'm a veteran or anything oh no of
course of course man i think that's the
beauty of
what what your
your route is
you know did you ever get jaded
in during that yeah totally in new york
i mean yeah i'm tired of it sometimes
where it's like what am i doing this
isn't really comedy this is like a
writing workshop where everyone hates
you and no one wants to be there
yeah yeah yeah yeah
especially when you repeat the same
stuff you know like the open mics or
whatever yeah recycle stuff but yeah
it's uh
yeah it motivates you to write
yeah
considering all your new followers you
have definitely a lot more haters too
well i mean let's not encourage that oh
no yeah [ __ ] them haters bro
yeah hitting the hands came
uh what do you think about the will
smith situation do you agree with will
smith or do you empathize with chris
rock i mean you know what we decided i
mean i think comics still together no
matter what yeah will smith being a fan
of will smith
and seeing him do that and cuss like at
the same time like be violent and cuss
yeah like you can kind of see that
his life was kind of scripted too you
know like he's living a scripted life
he's not living like a real
reality you know yeah but chris rock man
[ __ ]
i've seen chris rocks roast people
score on people
and for him to like bite his tongue it
looked like he bit his tongue too yeah
he didn't he could have went at him oh
yeah i heard his kills early murders
i heard uh greg fitzsimmons say that on
joe rogan's podcast that uh
chris rock went up after
a little guy kevin hart i think and then
kevin hart did amazing and then chris
rock made him look like an open miker so
yeah i think i mean i heard him talking
about that too
he was up there working new stuff
and then chris went up on it and
just [ __ ] murdered
i can tell it wasn't staged too because
he did a show chris rock did a show
afterwards there for his tour
and uh you know you got a standing
ovation i'm pretty sure everybody saw
that i saw that video well like his
opener
like it was more like he brought it up
but he was trying to move past i don't
know what to say about it or i hope i
have something to say later yeah
yeah i mean he's biting his time he's
he's got time on his side yeah for sure
he just has to wait it out and
everyone's on his side already he
doesn't have to say anything right i
think he's still choosing a higher out
he could easily just go back on like
easily
in the moment yeah like you were saying
i saw a lot of takes on it too like one
of my favorite takes was
uh
he
like will smith doesn't know he's will
smith
like why would you stay married to
someone that's
having sex with your your son's best
friend
like you can be will smith you can just
like
you know you can bang jada's mom you
know
i'd be friends with uh whatever yeah or
whatever his name is
jaden yeah yeah
jaden tweeted that's what they do
that people they think oh something
about the bank
you know like i'd be definitely cool
with jaden you're like yo i'm gonna be
like tail where's where's your mom at
actually i think they should allow
that at certain shows
that you can come up there and try to
hurt you and then part of the show where
you you have to fight for your jokes so
we could turn like comedy wrestling but
it's all like planned or whatever no i
mean that'd be funny too but yeah yeah
what would you do if someone came out
there trying to slap you i've tried to
wrap them up
and uh get them in a choke or see you've
been hanging out with joe rogan too much
bro like everybody told you exactly what
he will do we're gonna go for the shoot
and we're gonna go
for the legs you just go straight
they're coming at you they're probably
drunk
if they could if they're drunk they're
coming at you this is what you do huh
you [ __ ] just choke them out or what
would you wait till they're asleep or
you let them go i would keep them at a
distance maybe use the stool or the mic
stand you know swing it around my stand
i think is the better option yeah yeah
yeah i had drinks thrown at me and at
the grizzly pair in new york oh the
grizzly pair in uh west village yeah
i was doing like a small i went up there
and these people these lesbians were
heckling the whole time so i was like
yeah i'm the alpha dog here did you ever
shut the [ __ ] up did you have a bar to
get that spot no because you know they
didn't work every hour yeah and then she
was like
okay
and then uh he kept tackling and i was
like shut up she's like no i was like i
don't approve of your lifestyle wow
because they were lazy
and then she threw a drink at me because
you didn't approve it
what do you mean
i don't approve of their heckling
lifestyle
but i was using like old-school
homophobic language
to [ __ ] on hecklers
and she threw a drink at me and then she
threw another one she's only old school
though you're just like how you put that
it's just old school
your baby boom
yeah i channeled my inner boomer
sometimes these lesbians gotta
get reminded of
their place in the world
they're a minority
um but she was a black lesbian so maybe
it was even worse but yeah you should do
drugs that's like the bottom yeah the
highest because it flips
yeah
so we lost a lot of movies right like he
lost
like some movie in netflix
or uh
oscars
he's not doing another bad boys i think
that's like a blessing oh no what
ah i gotta go with martin lawrence
with martin lawrence yeah
what if they do bad boys but they kill
them off like early
they just use the notes and they do like
paul walker and just edit him into the
movie
like we have enough of you on film we
don't need you anymore they got his
like shark tales or whatever
yeah animated show he did or it's
literally now that shark's tail
character for bad boys
can't even have will smith's image or
whatever
it's like the chef in south park
yeah yeah yeah
oh hell no
make him say stupid [ __ ] too
yeah
i don't know man
he did he does uh you think he'll come
up with another rap album and start
cussing him getting jiggity with it too
i like it yeah keep my name about your
[ __ ] man yeah
it's like the will smith dance
who has to die for a fresh prince to be
a king who has to die
was it it wasn't chris will smith then
what are you talking about
oh to be the king yeah he's always going
to be a prince
bell
yeah he did die
i think jada wanted to be a queen she
couldn't just she couldn't take princess
i mean you're supposed to marry me queen
if you're the king though
not supposed to marry a princess you
know what jada did jada did like if any
girl gives a guy an attitude they can
actually say like hey don't be all jada
right there like
you need to do that with will now too
right don't will smith me or whatever
it's just like he thought he would be
cool and be like oh man he defended his
woman but it's like you were offended by
a joke you're
easily uh triggered into doing something
horrible
you know it's just like very very
uh bad luck i mean there's like the
[ __ ] you know
gangster
perspective and then there's like the
civilized
uh oscar white people what was that like
how was that night the final straw like
i was the oscar
he probably had an idea he was going to
win the best actor
like how was that like he had to show up
like i don't get it i you know what the
footage i haven't seen yet was the
actual look
that jada gave
that she gave will i know she wrote her
eyes during the joke but there was like
a moment where he was like wow this was
a nice joke it was a nice one yeah but
that whole moment i need to see like i
know like if he was just like determined
like should i do it now like i don't
know that part that's like a grassy
knoll i mean this is why they don't
nominate black people at the oscars
yeah
that's why they have all white oscars
nobody did [ __ ]
no one did no one like
i mean there's a bunch of [ __ ]
they're like whatever the status quo is
keep the show going whatever that was
wait what was tyler perry one of the
actors that came to consol will
yeah but i think denzel did or something
if tyler perry was one of them he was
probably in on it
all right let's murder this hollywood
[ __ ] and come to atlanta because he just
built a big-ass movie studios and all
that yeah i'm sure you guys never know
bro
that would be interesting
will smith has media
yeah he hasn't dressed like a woman all
black man dressed like a woman yeah
offset their masculinity hell yeah she's
probably trying to change the game by
dressing as a woman
for 40 movies
and the broadway show someone uh they're
funny why is he going to play that too
that dress up as a woman also
yeah yeah again
like louie
anderson yeah
and that was great
oh yeah baskets
yeah
but uh do you think that he's just
trying to uh dress like a woman that's
why he made his wife be bald so that he
could play her more easily
yeah
yeah this is the transition
like he's gonna uh caitlyn jenner
dude that will be so [ __ ] awesome if
anybody deserves to win woman of the
year will be will smith
first black woman yeah like the or i
don't know if that's true what if i mean
damn dude prefer for what's his name
kris jenner
i mean uh
no no no uh what was caitlin's bruce
bruce bruce jenner right uh dead name in
her bro that's crazy because like what
we know about the kardashians and for
him to be married to like the leader
like this is the leader of the mall
not only did it ruin his olympic
reputation but not even ruining i don't
want to get on roads but
he just transitioned like that's like
the worst thing like if you're dating a
girl you're about to get married and
then you guys break up and then you find
out like she was like man i hate all men
and just got with the woman
you think that was like bruce's
motivation part of part of his
motivation i don't know
like i hate all women and then just why
did he why does he become one then
because he wants to prove that he could
be a better one
he won one woman of the year chris chris
[ __ ] kardashian ain't never wanted
transgenders for killing it leah
thompson [ __ ] yeah caitlyn jenner
is what the swimmer the swinger yeah
record
yeah she looks like a dude she's like
it's not like she's like a feminine dude
she's like a normal dude she's got a
swimmer's build yeah
yeah i mean
who really cares about female swimming
that much do you think that that was
like do you think that was like i'm
going to dominate female swimming like
who cares like why would you go through
this that kind of creates creates
opportunity right if you ain't killing
it as a man
if you're doing it you know if you want
to be like slick about it like you know
what i'm gonna try my
i'm gonna try to take my talents and uh
be become a woman
and uh otherwise being
like sign up for
like these different types of sports you
should really ask the woman about this
yeah like what do you think mansplaining
about what
yeah thomas
yeah
yeah what he said female swimming is not
that serious so
are you a big fan of nails swimming for
the record
i'm not even a fan of male swimming
though
yeah i don't know
i don't really care for transgender what
would jordan peters
i mean like
unfair because they don't have to get
their period and you know they don't
want to shout babies or but you're ties
you guys have like a lot of ladies
do you think i'm transgender no
why would you ask me that
i said yes
yes
because he was asking about transgender
before
you know well
not with that if anything it makes me
now think you're transparent now it's
now it's like if you put makeup on hans
and put a nice little like hairdo on him
i could look like an ugly woman
dude i don't know you could be [ __ ]
though
i don't like the way you're looking at
it
the shades do
it doesn't take much to be a hot girl i
think you can kill it both ways
i mean i have yeah you can be a
abg
what's that american born gucci
american-born goo no oh nice to me oh
you guys are gonna say geisha but yeah
okay
asian baby girl
um but yeah i mean i uh
i i don't think you're trans
i think like the sports thing is like
the liberals don't really play sports so
they're like whatever put them in your
play give them a roll
it's like they don't really know
they don't really care about competition
because they don't compete with anything
usually that's all you should play
football
there's no other way there's no girls
that transition into men and then play
manly sports yeah it's always like dudes
that transition into women and then
dominate women's sports
but uh you'll see right there's a couple
of transgender people and felon fox and
mma not ufc
um but yeah i mean i don't think it's
a good thing to do i uh i think it's
stupid
i think it's like yeah you want a lower
level of competition and it's an easy
way to get that and it's like sort of
cowardly so okay but if you look at it
okay
it's it's not really fair
if they can compete with like
women i mean well they consider
themselves women i really don't know how
to the vocabulary of this you know [ __ ]
them you're not a woman yeah okay well
it was well it's not really fair then
because
you know
what were you supposed to tell them
we're supposed to tell them okay give up
you can't compete with the men compete
with the man yeah or a transgender as a
woman though yeah
that would be entertaining
you know you were born a woman inside or
whatever that case maybe men sports
there's no protection anyone can join
men's sports you can have like two dicks
you can have seven dicks you can have
china start letting women even join
men's sports yeah if you want to come up
to that place behind the wnba no no no
no
no
women's sports
do that you can't do that yeah well
wouldn't it be you know
if the wnba and nba just like
women get dominated do you know how many
reality shows you come up from there's
like people [ __ ] each other locker
room and
you know like a lesbian love hate
relationship with like the austin
there's just two people that look
exactly the same [ __ ]
one slightly skinnier
right
yeah that'd be great just
but they wouldn't be competitive like
women aren't as good at sports
uh what if i say i'm at [ __ ] and i
compete in the special olympics i
identify as a [ __ ] yeah i'd do that i
wouldn't punch that
i lost
it's a bunch of people i mean they don't
get much out of special olympics though
right that's for funsies yeah
call yourself a [ __ ] i mean i think
that's that's okay yeah what other
people call me a [ __ ] too i didn't
call you a [ __ ] yeah that's fine yeah
yeah i'm good with that
determination baby
representing up here in atx i mean i
don't think it's a big problem i think
like if it becomes bigger then we should
address it but like right now it's just
like that one person so like [ __ ] it it
doesn't really matter
but you know it's it's not good it's
like you shouldn't have that like it
ruins the whole idea of it and it's like
some women compete
and then
so if you had the opportunity to do
something about it what will be your
move
no transgenders in women's sports you
can compete with the men or have your
own league
like what like what is that like you you
have to compete with women i'm a woman i
gotta compete with
people that i think i look like are
there not
how do i feel about that because i i get
your point and it's definitely not fair
but i i get the america argument like
this is america you sound like you're
taking away freedoms you know and like
if you're a woman and man and you can
sign up for whatever the [ __ ] you want
to do there was like a transgender
woman or male whatever in a women's
prison that try to uh impregnate two of
the women in there she can't do that
she's a woman that's not how that it was
a man in a woman's prison oh yeah you're
creating our culture of impregnating
women
i'm a favorite
so how'd that go so uh is the baby happy
now or
i know okay having a baby in prison that
sounds like a planned baby right there
it means three well what do you think
about like a transgender person going to
man's prison because they look like a
woman they're probably going to get
raped it would be worse it's just no
it's just like the nba if you can hack
it
like if you can they'll be safe it's
like hitting a jackpot
transgender
yeah you're gonna be surrounded by me
sex all day
well i don't know how much the [ __ ]
can take i guess if
what if there's sex at it they're just
dying about that life they got locked up
on purpose
i'm sure there's some gay guys going to
prison on purpose for free i mean at
least for the woman i need homeless
people that would go to jail during when
it's cold you know safer
and you know like just going for dick
i don't know it's kind of like shelter
for them i guess i don't know she'll
turn that [ __ ] in her ass
shelf yeah
for that one
it
is it is that is that
that's what you call it yeah
it's in the small black bridge
yeah can you get another one for me
three total getting one for yourself
oh yeah so people are actually
commenting i i didn't even notice about
this we're probably like offending so
many liberals in austin
they say the person with the best mic is
speechless
what
oh they're talking about you uh the
person with the what the best mic oh
that's mike i'm just really high sorry
i don't know someone said no
nope sorry you're gonna have to settle
for me you know this splat yeah yeah we
all know this
oh she was in dallas yeah
shout out to this
so
um participating in the sport is a
privilege not a right
maybe you could turn the sensitivity of
the mic down and turn the volume up for
the gain up
left
good job
he's got the gun blue
are you supposed to be catching those
chopsticks instead okay
do you feel like um
it was a lot harder for you as an asian
male or it's easier for you as a nation
now
in comedy just in general life
in general
uh
carter
why
because no one will [ __ ] me
what
dude
you're making people in texas go god
damn them korean people are hilarious
man that one dude man
dude
yeah i think it is harder to get [ __ ]
as an asian though yeah like it's not an
apparently sexy race
war less masculine you know there's like
a masculinity thing here that's also
very hans nice to allow his sister on
the pod yeah
yeah do we look alive are you guys
related
yeah you know what i know it's mexican
her eyes are way bigger than mine
yeah
yeah at least you have a nose bridge
though so i won't make fun of you what's
the nose on here
right here oh no like a hot asian is
that no but like that distinguishes east
asians
that's crazy man uh when i heard white
people were claiming jesus
i was like none of them named their kid
jesus
yeah you mexicans did well with that
claimed that bro i mean in shiva indian
sanctuary jesus christ
holy minority's name
asian bridges tend to fall after a year
or so
okay i i have a what the
surgery
no not plastic surgery
just what is that surgery a different
type of yeah
metal surgery
i got gastric sleeve surgery
it's not for your nose bridge though
right look at that
like uh
it's like a weight loss surgery oh nice
yeah my parents were like hey do you
want it
i was like you're like hey yeah
when you grow up like fat in an asian
household you get treated like the same
as if you have down syndrome i thought
they treat you all like i thought they
treat y'all like you got the rich
genetic testing done
that's probably like a different culture
like
i remember the value thickness in asia
they don't value thickness
also they're like white women when sir
mix-a-lot came out with big butts on i
like big butts
a flat booty was the thing before before
surfing look how giant her
curvaceous booty is
let's flatten this down
this is so big
let's uh sew up those feet
you small
flat feet flat ass that's what makes a
perfect asian woman yeah and sideways
vagina
oh slanted
i mean mine looks pretty straight okay
see how it's gonna happen if you've seen
your own
i mean is it vagina
asian [ __ ] are fatter
are they i mean like ph fat or like
agency
just because i've been looking at a lot
of
internet documentation but you can't
tell because it's all pixelated what are
you talking about you can't tell man
that's really good we've been watching
anime porn a lot of asian people
[ __ ] are like the fatty kind and not
like the open wound kind more like yeah
like the actual camera they're more like
tucked in yeah
it's like yeah
that's very dainty they're more
connected
they got two little
lobes
like if the fortune cookie like touched
each other yeah
this is how fortune cookies got invented
yeah yeah so it looks better so maybe
they're like oh look how fat you want to
crack this open
for the good news i don't know sorry
oh man
you know i was actually discussing one
thing about uh the whole bang bang thing
like um
people were hitting me up about it after
he he did that [ __ ] with uh tony
but he's he's called me like a
wet back and a
[ __ ] spit before someone said turn
the mic sensitivity down
he did it jokingly but uh still you know
i could have went on tmz for that [ __ ]
after you don't do that you don't do
that to comics yeah after no before
well how did he say it
uh we were outside i think back door
comedy club i mean he was pretty wasted
but we were
the context wasn't like he was calling
me that
he was asking more like how would you
feel like he called me that how would i
feel because
it was like a joking way but still like
for him to be that offended about that
one word
to like you know not even take his phone
call i think that was just [ __ ] salty
he's a very chinese maneuver he saw an
opening and he was like i shall use this
yeah my chinese ways
yep
can you walk
white people have it hard
well you know hard these days they're
trying to play the game of capitalism
they're catching up
yeah real good
real good
find their way in
they don't know how much of their soul
to sacrifice and how much of it to keep
like americans have been practicing for
years
so they know like how to uh you know
like sell their soul in the correct way
but like chinese people they're like
it's all or nothing with them
yeah
they hate america i don't know if
americans are doing it in the correct
way though
in the most sustainable way yeah okay
okay okay
what are the comments are you reading
the comics now yeah
anybody anybody talking i think someone
called me plump like a dumpling
oh yeah something how do you feel about
that how do you feel
you totally should have changed
we should just shout out everybody right
yo shout out to hope clear
hope clear for showing up to the
classified comedy showcases
um yeah
any any shout outs do you want any shout
outs you have zero
no no
this entire time i'm trying to help
you
yeah
i thought you would dig in when we were
talking about
we were like i'm not offended now she
was being a woman she was like
it's not my place to
[ __ ] oh
yeah i didn't want to talk without
permission oh by the way guys uh to get
a blog follow me on instagram from you
guys
start plugging [ __ ]
um what is this live on youtube yeah oh
that's cool
what do you all think
subway last week i heard about that cool
[ __ ] man are they bringing shooting back
home are they bringing mass shootings
back again violent again
the shootings that happen in other
countries
they see it as
an act of terrorism
but
you know like the [ __ ] that's happening
with ukraine and russia i've heard like
the cia
they they stir [ __ ] up to you know to
start wars or whatever the hell case may
be that's what you think it was i don't
really think it's actually act of
terrorism i think people that actually
work for someone
that was hired to just kill people or
kill themselves
just to start stirring [ __ ] up
politically you know i think they're
hired to do that [ __ ] and they just say
that they dismiss it by saying it's the
terrorist attack
i don't know it's stupid so it's like
sandy hook it's like everything i think
all of this is connected man that's how
god
what do you think is more likely that
they have to hire people or that there's
enough crazy people in this i think they
kind of train them or they put
like don't you think like we produce
enough people that would do that like
look at our society don't you think
someone would shoot it up
yeah they maybe they just hire crazy
people
they got a profile on them you know
it's easy to profile somebody now what
does that do for them what does it do
for them yeah they get to die that's
what they want no like for the cia like
why would they go through the extra
effort instead of just waiting for
someone to shoot people up
i guess to brush it a little bit
just to create chaos great chaos he
liked it yesterday like the vietnam war
was from the battleship
just so we can talk about banning guns
or whatever the case may be you know i
don't know even if they start chaos it's
hard to predict where it will go so like
just starting chaos seems like an empty
goal but did you hear about the the [ __ ]
that happened with pablo escobar
it was like they killed like a shitload
of kids they bombed like certain
neighborhoods so the community could
turn on escobar to kind of like
end his regime
because they're getting attacked yeah he
was actually doing a lot
for his community i guess i mean he had
a shitload of money
but they just did that under his
leadership
there's no pablo escobar for the
brooklyn shooting
right well they have who they have
now
i do right yeah eric andrews
i don't know i think that's i'm not sure
but i think it's just like we don't
really take care of our people and then
we give them all guns and what do you
think's gonna happen
people are gonna shoot each other like i
mean look what's happening in texas now
it's able to carry an unpermanent
or like unpermitted unconcealed
concealed license yeah but you can just
carry a gun bro and nobody's shooting no
baby's just concealed i forget i forget
i mean like you can carry a gun without
a permit
oh okay okay
yeah it's open carry you can just carry
a [ __ ] gun you can own a gun i think
yeah open carry open carry yeah sixth
street has shootings there like once
every everything i hear about that i
hear about the shootings on sixth street
too is that why is it is it like people
getting drunk and with guns
or is it like people out there just to
get ready to kill someone i think it's
just
just
wishes and then drunk people with guns i
think it's like because things are so
shitty you're more likely to be like
well i have nothing left to live for
like i have no
good life i might as well risk jail time
and shoot someone i'm drunk just take
yourself out you feel that way i can't
totally relate to that you're not
shooting somebody else but yeah yeah
yeah i mean that's why i did comedy i
was like there's nothing else my life is
worth so i might as well waste it making
jokes and making fun of people you think
you're wasting it i think you're doing a
really good job at it i think there's a
lot of uh
you have a lot of down time that's kind
of like theirs too yeah
yeah it don't mean you have a lot of
time to party you have a lot of down
time i mean but you don't even know them
bro
it is meeting us though
doing stand up is meaningless you know
what i mean yeah
like it's not like
a product yeah all right 10 20 years
from now it doesn't matter actually
yeah but people love his name but
nobody's like re-listening well george
carlin a little bit but lenny bruce
somebody's listening
because like right now with with you you
know the whole
everything that's been happening there's
a lot of opportunity that you can kind
of like expand your name and whatever
you want from comedy yeah but i think
you're pretty happy with where you're at
right now it's going pretty well for you
so i mean i think that's kind of a
accomplishment i think people are very
powerful and i'd rather talk directly to
the people than like you know make a
little widget that they can use
and it's more important to like be like
hey let's figure out where we're going
what we're doing and make fun of the
correct things
um but uh yeah i mean i think like uh
because everyone's an individual they're
like it's only about me my life is the
only one that matters i need to get the
most money and be the most comfortable
and have the most pleasure other people
are just like meaningless and empty as
opposed to like a communal society where
like we're all in this together we're
creating a country together and we're
progressing and going to mars like since
we're not doing anything like what the
[ __ ] are these people let me just shoot
them i'm bored it's it'll give me
meaning so then like if other people are
more meaningless then it's easier to
shoot them so there's names like four
comics in my head in dallas that are
that i come about and i'm sure they're
gonna end up shooting a comedy club or
something
yeah it's just meaningless that selfish
guy you're talking about i don't think
he's gonna
do anything with a common career because
like
you can't just really [ __ ] on everybody
you can't just be really just selfish
plan to get
booked everywhere you know what i mean
right it's a communal thing yeah
it's all about the
society or you know being a part of the
larger comedy scene oh yeah
and some people are not good at that and
some people are too good at that and
that's all they care about they don't
actually do the comedy part right
which is why i like stand up it's the
perfect mix you got to focus on yourself
and you also have to like
you know well you grow as a person too
like you actually figure out who you are
and write off of that and that's how it
becomes art i think comedy
it's people say it's an art and i i
didn't really realize it because it
could easily been like oh i'm just going
to bars [ __ ] telling jokes and
drinking
but once when you do it for long enough
you start figuring out who you are and i
think that's when it becomes an art like
you start like just manifesting into
like a true comic yeah because it's your
life this is who you are this is what it
is yeah but i don't like who i am after
discovering it
well yeah that's that's kind of the
thing too you know you realize
you know
what's so bad about you i mean everyone
else is like that everyone is that much
better no i definitely people
yeah
i mean myself and i mean i'm just
distant yeah
detached i think like i don't
yeah
people i mean it's weird telling people
this but you know
and people
i think it's like my way of connecting
with people is stand up because without
stand up it wouldn't be uh
it wouldn't be as easy to do this
yeah jokes are there's a way to connect
with people yeah talk to them you see
their faces it's hard to be like i want
to shoot these people now and you're
like relying on them to laugh at your
jokes like giving them [ __ ] though
so it's like i guess if you start
bombing then you can start hitting
people they're gonna like [ __ ] these or
even bomb when you're kicking people
when i found them i started that's how i
never bomb
bombing i'm gonna start charging to come
out here and cut your
grass pretty much what my life is
without calming just trying to get work
so it might be later tonight then
i have a question
yeah what's your what's your bomb no
what's your kill to bomb ratio
i don't know
is that supposed to be keeping track of
this yeah you don't have an uh what's it
called an excel spreadsheet of this yeah
you know i assumed you would have
um
i mean it's pretty high now because i
stopped doing open mics and that made me
a happier person
um i have enough shows where i can still
do practice enough
um because one ten minutes that is like
three open mics running around all over
town
so
you know i'm having a good time um you
know not bombing i think it's healthy
and good because then you don't realize
that that negativity can exist so
then you are less likely to be
angry or fearful or like hedging your
bets and trying to soften the bomb as
opposed to
exaggerating the kill
yeah
i get what you're saying
but yeah i mean but you do still bob
right yeah what's your ratio what's your
number well every second eight kills two
bombs you know and what kind of
counts what counts as a bomb
you know what i mean
yeah she didn't laughs
i would say like no laughs okay no zero
less yeah that's actually kind of hard
to do yes that's absolutely impressive
that's impressive
yeah
yeah people manage
because people laugh nervously sometimes
too
well i think uh
a bomb could be a bomb even if you get
laughs if you get off stage and you're
like holy [ __ ] that was horrible what am
i doing with my life yeah that's true
yeah
so anything can be a bomb but overall i
would say i don't have a bomb in a while
yeah that means
you need to bomb them right
i'd rather not
um but yeah i mean i think uh with open
mics some people get uh
used to the bombs
i think you learn some bad habits going
to the open mics after a certain time
yeah like you don't really see a lot of
headliners at open mics there's a reason
for that
yeah
seeing what you're interested or
whatever yeah it's not weird like i
would i thought like when i get you know
i make it i'm gonna [ __ ] go to mike
still i'm gonna stay true to the people
but it's like yeah
i'm not i still go to open i mean i'm
i'm not pleased
yeah completely you don't go to any open
mics no nice
tony told me not to he says i got bad
habits
yeah yeah yeah because you you know
you're playing for comics and stuff and
it's it's uh
yeah that's definitely not a bad idea
i mean
yeah i miss having the respect of my
peers and
getting to uh you know walk off stage
after i kill and having people think i'm
funny or something
um but yeah i mean uh i think it's all
like a house of cards like all that
respect you get from the open mic scene
is like very ephemeral and
it's not like you can't really build a
foundation on that like at some point
you have to go beyond that
and start selling out and doing or not
selling out but like selling tickets at
comedy clubs and actually doing comedy
yeah right i mean that's part of the
work too
some people just don't understand i
don't even know what steps to take
for the next level right start gaining
from it and you don't want to be too
much of a road hack and just spend all
your time on the road just making idiots
laugh you also want that you know
credibility in the city that's what all
those [ __ ] road hacks wish they had
yeah um
so i think you need to balance
but i love city comedy more than like
urban trump supporter comedy
i just feel like there's a highlight
they have a story about this little
urban trump community
just like mediocre sets in front of
people that uh
want uh they watch comedy for the first
time yeah they're not very sophisticated
in their
humor they just want big bang theory
that's a really good show
that's what you call it when uh people
eat curry after they curious they have a
big bang theory out of their anus
i mean the reason i could talk is
because i was drinking that's a
reference to big bang
theory
i think nobody is
diarrhea i really watch the show
curry's not even an indian thing british
people came up with that
you know that is that
no it's like in british people i just
found this out like a year ago
but you know you can call that it's like
panda express for indians
that's a lot of asian food
goopy rice coopin coop and rice curry
um
someone says what's your favorite joke
you've ever written
who you asked you gotta pay for that
[ __ ] i'm not gonna ruin a joke on a
podcast
yeah
wouldn't you ever hear your minute here
before
it's the wrong context
oh yeah it's like a conversation between
you and the audience and it's not we
wouldn't translate on a podcast no for
sure
that's what people don't care yeah we
talked about the will smith bro i've
been waiting to talk about this man oh
yeah and you got to uh
get something off your chest
oh yeah about what came to someone
trying to cancel you
oh yeah
pong ding dong he
i mean it was all a domino effect it is
man and it's crazy how it all worked out
because i really i was really worried
dude because i was out here getting
opportunities to do shows
and then hank i mean paul came down here
and why did you call him han
i'll get y'all mixed
no uh no and then i introduced them to
uh
a couple of people i know
and then apparently one of those guys
that i introduced them to
was the one that filmed it
and uh it's john heis buddy i don't
think they're friends anymore
but uh he hit me up like him and david
was like hey what the hell is up with
this dude i was like dude i have no idea
i don't know why i hit him up too like
hey what what happened
why would you post that
and then he tried to give me a speech
about like how offended he was i was
like i don't know man
and then uh i posted uh that i was like
on the side of comedy like if anybody's
gonna cancel you it's not gonna be
another comedian you know like comics
there's some some there's something
about not recording each other and
trying to blast each other out yeah and
that's what i was in favor for and i got
i got a [ __ ] a lot of backlash for
that too
and then um
then he
eventually blocked me and then he
punched that asian person i didn't punch
anybody
and then uh they eventually blocked me
and
and then you know just this whole [ __ ]
just spiraled down
and then the opposite would i mean you
kind of got
uh lucky from it i mean you deserve it
you're a hard working comic but like
[ __ ] it you know whatever happens
happens whatever tony's whatever tony's
uh mindset was it bucket it doesn't
matter as long as it helps you out
another comic that deserves it that
that's really what we got out of this
you know yeah
because i don't know if he's going to
get booked it's not what he used to i
mean even if he does
probably to like the liver crowd
or whatever the greatest
liberal liberal oh yeah
yeah i don't think liberals know him i
mean it was very short news cycle that's
what i'm saying like i don't know why he
would do that but and then you know just
made sense afterwards like he just
he wanted his uh he wanted to be on tmz
or [ __ ] new york post or whatever
just think about it because i heard that
tony try to reach out to him try to
reach out to him as a comic
and then he didn't he didn't take his
calls
and then he get up on tmz
whatever the case may be and it wouldn't
have been a big deal but like because he
didn't take his calls because he wanted
like you i think it was just all
narrated to try to
you know get some buzz
well he only provided like a very narrow
perspective he wasn't really like trying
to shed more light on it he was just
like this horrible thing happened to me
yeah i'm such a victim well i was doing
shows in austin before that situation
happened i saw the material that
tony was working on
and it all played a part to what he was
it was a set you know yeah um
yeah and i just i just thought it was
comedy i didn't think he was coming
after
him you know what i mean yeah but you
know just sucks dude now we gotta look
out for comics and [ __ ]
yeah everyone's back their phones
yeah but if you're asian people ask you
like what do you think of it
did anyone ask you yeah yeah yeah i
didn't even know that word was that
offensive i don't
oh yeah on stage yeah did you throw
something at someone's windshield and no
shank
what's that what that word means was
that the [ __ ] in your armor look was
that the
did that get to you
no it turned out
it honestly turned me on it was
it was like dirty talking yeah i was
like yeah
see why
why did they yell that out at you
i just tried to have someone guess my
ethnicity
yeah no they were just like
you're a little [ __ ] but not too much
ching
yeah they were polite about it they
weren't polite about it
about it
[Laughter]
anyone doing that with the n-word you're
a
you're just the perfect balance there's
black people and there's edwards
chris rock
uh yeah yeah i mean it's wheels
you can change that up
damn man yeah i've seen i've seen people
post about the wills stuff and
i guess the algorithm catches up because
people
can't stop talking about it
uh and i was just like i heard
everybody's take
on it and i was like i can't wait to
[ __ ] i've been wanting to talk about
this since it happened we were actually
watching it live during an open mic so
right after it happened were you
watching the oscars
it was at one nostalgia open mic in
dallas and it was they had it on they
had the [ __ ] [ __ ] on every screen and
we were still doing an open mic and then
when we saw it like almost every comic
like decided to like do a take on it oh
my god so yeah it's been a great time
i couldn't believe it happened like in
front of us like live yeah it was great
i had to watch it in japanese
why
it was on twitter they translated it
oh okay
where is smither
my name is
hello where's smith
keep my wife's name out your [ __ ]
mouth
ah that one hurts down now i don't feel
like you're my name on your [ __ ]
mouth buddy
thank you come again whatever you'd be
like hey
that was his piss
or am i
like i felt like there was like a you
know like real life situation it's like
what am i doing what is is my frame
bigger than the other person's frame am
i looking ridiculous i mean he was way
bigger than chris when you see him on
the stage like his
his eyes were just holding a little
smirk when he did it
oh dude yeah he walked off like it was
just like an emoji
that was a pen
somebody powdered his hand before he
smacked chris rock that was like a
[ __ ] would have been funny
even chris would have been like all
right that's kind of funny i'm mad
i don't know man that [ __ ] just i mean
the way christopher reacted i still
can't believe it i can't believe he was
just
oh well is this improv is everybody yeah
an improv that left everyone feeling
uncomfortable and what made everyone
look bad yeah the perfect that's most of
improv
you're the perfect line for if it was
improv because if it was you gotta you
could get an answer like will smith just
left the [ __ ] out of me like he just
announced it yeah in case everyone
didn't know
and uh that's when [ __ ] will started
yelling but like
i don't know dude that [ __ ] was amazing
i feel bad for chris but like wow
actually i needed that i didn't even
know that there were three female
hosts
like i remember watching that and then
finding out like the day i thought
it was cool chris she didn't really say
anything either
did i miss something
what did amy sure say
she was acting like i was i was back
there changing did i miss something like
it feels like the vibe is different and
there's an assault joke though it was
funny that's the song i thought they
were cool though yeah like say something
like get well out of there like hey man
you know
gotta get out of here they must have
known that he was going to get an oscar
so they must have thrown a wheel he has
to stay you know what i mean
it's like they kick him out and then
they're like then the winner is ah [ __ ]
he's in the top
i'm accepted with this award
you want to
she
[Music]
was like two years ago
you probably have that sit down with
will
in the living room yeah you can't give
will smith no [ __ ] cool ass
cool guy
uh uh parts anymore in movies he has to
be the bad guy now
that'd be cool yeah i wanted to see will
smith be like the whole [ __ ] villain
because he was a villain in suicide
squad but that wasn't you know still
it's him he has all the black version of
tom cruise rose he's always the lead
yeah superstar yeah yeah
[ __ ] he's black crews man just record
that they're saying the audience
oh oh yeah
nice
oh man it's been burning me up
shout out to chris audio's not that
weird i love that guy
hello chris rock for that
yeah
true fam true mexican fandom
it's pretty quick um there's like an
audio echo or something
is that what people are saying
it's yeah of cool
the audio the echo yeah
whatever
that's what you're going to get
like auto-tune is like some t-pain [ __ ]
happening
i mean you did put effort in we moved
the thing back around and we have to
turn it down like the whole time the
echo yeah just happened
maybe we could turn it down so that
people
picked [ __ ] up
usually they're just complaining him
loving somebody complaining
yeah
oh yeah thanks for having us man it's
been fun dude yeah that's your favorite
oh yeah so you ready for kill tony
tonight yeah there's gonna be another
crowd yeah
that was always good there but yeah even
if you use this question
i don't know
i usually don't know
i don't know
i usually know in the green room before
30 minutes before dave lucas in town i
don't know
either montgomery
i got you you got david doesn't need an
indian and a vietnamese lady
so what do you think about the uh
whole
you know
coronavirus
and they had it it was a section where
like you didn't take the vaccine you
were probably like still more immune if
you already talked about it
um i think it lasts shorter
um
i think vaccines and having it having
had it is like the best defense
but i think like if you didn't have it
and you were like fat and old and you
shouldn't get that yeah
like the numbers like most people who
got vaccinated survived but people
uh
[Music]
is it worth getting the vaccine if
you've already had it
you should get it one more time and then
get the vaccine i think that's the sweet
spot
did she go from open nighttime
yeah yeah what was it like for you it
was sort of weird it was like being
carsick
it felt different it felt like a new
disease it felt like the
tick-tock of diseases this is after you
got your shot before yeah
yeah feel like normal sickness right
yeah that's how i was going to do the
whole tasting and then
smelling
the nausea i had the shits
i was sweating on every part of my body
oh
yeah i was out of the country when i
realized i got it
i got
no no in costa rica i was staying in a
hostel too
and i was like
you know
hush about it you know stay with people
but i was still like hiking
and
and living my life yeah hiking helped a
lot like it's really it was really hard
on my lungs without just the altitude
there but afterwards i started feeling
so much better
also asking people for water on the way
up how bad the hike was you want to
share water
yeah
yeah more one thing
it's boring
we're done with it
what do you think will smith thinks
about kobe oh my god
is
is
helicopters and grand canyons
yes
he's like let's see how much i can get
away with
let me just do whatever the [ __ ]
peel the next option
all right
what do you think about ukraine
uh
sell it
uh
[Music]
he wasn't looking out for us
[Music]
that's a player
[Music]
is
is
tom cruise will yell at
people this is like a tom cruise moment
instead of jumping on the couch
[Music]
would you ever want to be a
scientologist
no no
[Music]
like
money or like respect or whatever you
know whatever their
thing is
[Music]
on
yeah
um
[Music]
[Music]
you got some sausage fingers probably
yeah
[Music]
i thought he's a senior citizen already
he looks great
he was on his hair for sure then right
it makes it worse he's a junior
grandfather
would you guys um buy
a piece of land on mars
or groupon
did you know they have that now
oh no it's just like you paid 20 bucks
to open that's the same thing as the
nfts like who's going to be in charge of
this is that this groupon the people in
charge of mars real estate i want white
people to like claim mars and then our
people just go there and take it from
them and be the opposite of
the united states
[Music]
he looks
he looks like he's in his 30s or 20s
even
where he took that snap
yeah did you see that picture where he
played
like smiling like a hater he had no idea
yeah that he's done that before
he's done that before when he like does
a gag they're friends right
yeah
our culture is stagnating we have no
future
instead of learning from experience
or is very individualistic
in a sense
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
yeah yeah
well i mean the internet wasn't even
what it is now back then for sure it
took a while for it to be people that's
kind of amazing yeah
now
but i mean you're great on a curve like
if other people had the internet and
who's the best at using the internet you
think
you're the best at it
he actually just got aol he just found
out
oh
um
[Music]
mosquitoes must know something about you
yeah
they don't want me to give them an std
mosquitoes
okay so cutting the grass will make the
water evaporate quicker
bro he's just trying to upsell you he's
just upselling you yeah we can provide
you a
service package
for you only for 40. yeah i mean i want
to
um i'll ask my landlord
is
ourselves
do i eat grass
salads
no i don't eat salad
[ __ ] i don't know
yeah
do you want to
call it a podcast sounds
hey guys
oh yeah what's the last person what's
the last person saying i'm not sure what
that has to do with the truth but okay
the guy on the right kind of looks like
this youtube guy called eric
oh yeah he's probably sexier